in this video i'm going to walk you
through the best way in my opinion to
pick the niche that you're going to
focus on to start your business so i
asked my instagram you know what are
some of the questions that you have and
uh this one came up a lot which is like
how do i pick my customer how do i pick
the niche like what's the process etc
and so obviously my book this guy it's
99 cents on amazon for those of you guys
who don't know are like ah it's not 99
cents the kindle is 99 cents because
it's digital the hard copy amazon
changes the prices but you can get a
hardback or you can get the digital one
for 99 since because that's the lowest
they would let me sell it for all right
anywho so picking the niche i think this
is something that's like wildly
misunderstood and i'll tell you where
most people get wrong is that they pick
a niche and they have
no idea about the niche all right and so
y combinator which is a venture it's
like an incubator type thing in silicon
valley they have their things that they
look for when they're investing
businesses and they're accepting them
into yc and one of the ones that was
really interesting to me is that they
look for past experience within the
space and because i think a big part of
that is that a lot of times new
businesses are not actually really new
they're slight iterations on things that
are old and candidly within my own
business experience i don't even do
anything new i just try and do stuff
better which people somehow poo poo on
it's like you go into dry cleaning and
do it better than everybody else and
still win like you could go into lawn
care and do it better than everyone else
and still win and i think that's wildly
underrated you don't need anything new
and so like i think that is a widely
underestimated component of having
strategy and business is just like how
do how am i get the use the value
equation in the book like i'm going to
provide more value to my customers than
anyone else can but like the actual
industry itself that you're serving
doesn't need to be new or different
right so that being said like service
with a smile wildly underrated but the
the piece that i want to hit on here is
that like i'll tell you this story
because i think it really drives this
point home so in allen our software
company that we recently sold a majority
stake in one of the agency owners you
know for nine months was just like never
making progress right like was always
hopping on was always having issues and
it was like his clients weren't getting
results he was like how do i get around
that and i was like you don't you need
to fix that and um it got to the point
where i just said listen man like you
don't know what you're doing which is
why your clients are getting results
period he said well i've got this one
guy who does who makes all this money
using our you know using the leads that
we get him and i was like okay well why
is he getting making money the other
ones aren't he's like well i don't know
and i was like right so that's not
because of you that's because of him and
so what i told him to do which was wild
at the time i said i need you i think
that you should close your agency i was
like i don't think you know anything
about real estate i said i think that if
you know how to get real estate leads
then you should go get your realtor's
license go generate your own leads and
go build a real estate business and
learn it and then once you have
succeeded in doing that then if you want
to then go make the agency and show
other people how to do it because you've
actually done it and so there's a tweet
by layla my wife she said like stop
listening to people about like sorry
stop listening people about how to play
the game who've never been anywhere but
the sidelines and the problem is too
many of the people who are watching this
right now y'all are on the sidelines and
have always been on the sidelines and
are trying to pick a niche to get into
to sell how to do the niche well that's
dumb you've never done it so a lot of
times people are trying to skip to a
higher leverage opportunity without
having done the requisite work of
understanding the niche which is why the
y combinator people look for like if you
want to make a software in the payment
space we'd love to see that you have
experience in the payment space because
there's so much stuff that you don't
know that you know when you actually
spend three five you know years doing
something in an industry you understand
the lingo you understand the avatar you
understand the problems and you can see
opportunities if you have an
entrepreneurial hat on there's always
problems in every industry which means
there's always opportunity and
fundamentally business is just solving
problems that exist with a and making
sure the math makes sense like that's
literally it it's like where is their
problem how much do they think this is a
problem and is there a way that i can
solve it and charge for it that's it
like that's really all that business is
and really how well you solve the
problem is going to dictate how much
virality your business has because if
you solve it really well people will
tell people and your your business will
grow right i think the problem that a
lot of people have is they didn't know
how to make an offer right is the
fundamental thing that is the beginning
of building a businesses you got to know
what you're selling and so that was a
problem for a lot of people and then
people got that problem solved and then
they told their friends and books sold
100 000 copies in six months with no
promotion and so i'm only i'm sharing
this because i couldn't write a book on
offers without having made a ton of
offers and i feel like there's too often
people who are trying to focus on a
niche who've never actually done the
thing in the niche and this is really
really rampant in the internet space
because everyone's trying to take a
shortcut to get there when they realize
like what i'm telling you right now
you're never going to get there because
you're not good enough like you're never
going to get there because you're not
good enough you have to do the rocky
cutscene you have to eat the [ __ ] for a
period of time so that you can get the
reps in so you can put your time under
the bar end so that you can actually get
good and before you are good you will
suck and you have to accept a long
period of sucking and you do enough
volume that eventually you'll suck so
little that you'll actually be good and
then at that point then you'll actually
have a real decision to make which is
i'm actually really good at this thing
now that i've learned do i want to teach
it to other people or i just want to do
more of the thing that i'm doing right
because like a realtor can then just
grow a team of 100 realtors and own the
entire thing which is what i'd recommend
this guy do right rather than have an
agency um that doesn't right and so this
is kind of where where i think the
problem is is that like i had another
question that was sent to me on
instagram which is like hey how do i
soft churn because a lot of my a lot of
my clients aren't getting results and
i'm like well duh he's like no he said
he said how do i sell from 10 000 100
000 a month when i don't have a lot of
testimonials i was like
you're not good at the thing that you're
supposed to be good at why you don't
have testimonials is why you're not
going 100 000 a month like he's making
the goal 100 000 a month rather than
being good
i i i have no words i have no words i
don't get it you know what i mean like
everyone's in such a [ __ ] rush that
you will never get there it is the
slowest path to getting there is to fool
yourself into thinking that you're good
something that you're not you have to go
and pull the thread and say which and
the thing is it's like well do what
you're passionate about whatever you're
not gonna be passionate about stuff that
you suck at what you have to do is like
which of these opportunities seem like
they have potentially have high leverage
and i'm gonna learn from the bottom
right it's like one of the best ways to
learn stuff is starting at the bottom
not because because it's the only option
but because if you understand the entire
pathway of of a client journey or of an
industry journey then you will have more
trench knowledge more depth of
experience that you will be then able to
apply people see my you know videos on
personal finance people see videos of
mine on sales people's videos online
recruiting people see videos of mine of
marketing and it's like how did you
acquire all these skills it's cause like
it's not like because i tried to jump to
the spot that i'm at you can't skip like
there's a sequence buildings are built
with foundations and your career is a
pyramid and the peak of that pyramid is
based on the depth of the foundation
that you build and so like i've said
this before and i'll say it again but
your work works on you more than you
work on it and so even though you might
not be getting paid in the period that
you're at just because you're struggling
doesn't mean you're failing and it means
and the thing is as long as you're
getting better you're making progress
and the progress is the success is that
you are getting better and like you will
turn the corner like that's an
inevitability if you put enough time in
period i promise you that if you don't
stop doing something for 10 years you'll
be really good at it period and if
you're really good at it you'll like
doing it ah right and if you like doing
it then at that point you won't wonder
why your business isn't making money
because you'll actually be good and then
you won't have these questions but the
questions that i get i would say a third
of them come from a very short time
horizon it's like why am i not a
millionaire it's been it's been 90 days
alex what the hell it's like well you
didn't put the five years in so if
you're trying to figure out what niche
you're gonna pick the point is to just
pick and then accept that you're not
gonna be overwhelmingly successful for
like five years every entrepreneur like
that i know of puts five years in before
before anything really happens and
you're like [ __ ] five years i probably
shouldn't tell new entrepreneurs that
yes you're gonna be very successful very
quickly you should quit your job and do
it it takes a long time to learn because
there's a lot of stuff you gotta know
gotta know how to generate leads you got
to know how to work leads you know got
to know how to set appointments you got
to learn how to close you got to learn
how to set up bank accounts you got to
learn how to transact you got to learn
how to do billing you got to learn how
to do payroll you got to like you got to
learn how to actually fulfill a product
you allowed to learn how to create a
customer journey got to learn how to
ascend people you got to learn how to
decrease churn you got to like there's a
lot of stuff you got to learn how to
recruit you got to learn how to hire you
got to like there's a lot of stuff that
you got to learn and so to think that
it's somehow going to take 90 days it's
like why do you think that you can get a
chemistry degree in four years and think
you can somehow be able to become a
masters in entrepreneurship in 90 days
it doesn't it doesn't give respect to
the game like you have to respect the
game like a lot of people have been
playing this for 40 years no one's
getting their master's degree for 40
years well some phds aren't right and
they're probably pretty good at whatever
their thing is right and so it's like to
think that you're going to beat guys
who've been playing the same game for 40
years on your first try in 90 days
doesn't respect the game and so like i
was fortunate that i started young i
started when i was 23. i mean the only
thing i could have done before that dude
without doing that is just start instead
of going to college but you have to you
have to put your time under the bar your
legs aren't going to grow until you have
like you can't do four squat workouts
and expect your legs to grow you'll get
better at squatting and that getting
better at squatting is a requisite for
having bigger legs but you still got to
put the volume in there's a depth of
understanding that happens with volume
that people cannot appreciate you gotta
do the boring work and you gotta love
the boring work and if you can do that
you won't lose because the only person
who's injecting this artificial timeline
on on you is you and so anyways it was
like one of the number one questions
that i was getting in my comments and
stuff it's like how do you pick the
niche how do you know where to start you
don't know where to start you just start
and then you start accumulating
knowledge and then you will learn it's
like reading books on sales before
you've actually had a sales call i'm
actually very against it i think you
should start selling and then read books
on sales because then the books will
actually make sense to you right like
trying to read 100 books on
entrepreneurship before you've actually
had a business is silly start a business
how do you start a business you get a
bank account get an llc and you figure
out what you're going to sell like
that's what that's what you do that's
how you start a business so it's going
to start with promotion and selling
because you can't even have the rest of
the stuff until you learn how to do that
and if you don't know what you're
selling it's because you probably won't
get the thing yet so you got to go like
get some industry experience right
that's why banks by the way they don't
loan to people who don't have industry
experience so if you're like hey i want
to get a you know loan to this was
actually a story i heard from from my
gym owner ended up working with us for a
period of time was in gym launch was he
wanted to start a gym and and get a loan
from the bank and they he went to like
10 banks and they all said no and they
said and he said the reason was because
he didn't have experience so what he did
was he went to uh bally's and worked at
bally's for like three or four years and
worked his way up to becoming the
personal training manager and then at
that point started his gym and he didn't
even need the bank loan at that point
because he had saved some money and he
learned how the business worked and lo
and behold he was like that was some of
the best advice i ever had so sometimes
you just got to get the industry
experience people just want to skip to
the last step when like there are
prerequisites to getting there which is
why prerequisites exist so this is uh
hopefully the the real answer to how to
pick your niche which is like you just
need to do something that is at least
not you know repelled from that you see
people making money in and then stick
with it for an inordinate amount of time
without convincing yourself that you're
smarter than you are which is a loose
paraphrasing of a twitter quote that i
can't remember who wrote it so anyways
if you're new i don't know if i said in
the beginning but my name is austin
mosey i own acquisition.com about 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you and if this is your first video
welcome to mozy nation and i'll see you
next vid bye